all right mercedes the the word game
wordle it's taking social media by storm
it's filling my twitter page i can't
stand it but it is trending this morning
for a bit of a different reason
frustration mercedes what have they done
to our wonderful games yeah people are
people are so upset about wordle world
fanatics are noticing that the game is
getting more difficult ever since the
new york times bought the word game last
month players have had more trouble
guessing those words they have not even
like they say they haven't even messed
with the game so nobody knows what is
going on here but for those of you that
don't know wordle first of all where
have you been but it gives it's a word
game that gives you six chances at
guessing a five letter word the green
boxes mean that you have a correct
letter and
the other the yellow means that that
letter is in the word but in the wrong
spot and it's just
it's just a fun game to play but it is
getting very frustrating i don't know if
you guys played with yesterday's word
i was so scared i wasn't gonna get it i
finally got it we're not on the wordle
we haven't jumped on the wordle train i
know i feel like now is the time you
think so maybe no it's late no now that
the trend is sort of waning mercedes i
feel like now is the time to jump on
board